This code should be really familiar to you because it's what
we saw in lesson three. One of the first plots you
created was a histogram, so let's see what this one looks
like. We can immediately notice
some important discreetness to this distribution.
There appear to be prices at which there are many observations,
but then no observations in adjacent prices. This makes sense if
prices are set in a way that applies to many of
the consumers. There are some purchases that involve much lower prices, and
if we are interested in price sensitivity, we definitely want
to consider what sort of variations is in these prices. Now,
I also want you to note that if we chose
a different bin width we might obscure this discreetness. Say if
I chose a bandwidth equal to ten. In this histogram,
we would miss the observation for some of the empty spaces
for the adjacent prices. So, it's no surprise that for
this very discreet data this histogram is a very biased model.